All right--so why is that--so it turns out that this little plastic ring thing, you can think of it as a graph
where each of the little plastic connectors is actually an edge between nodes
and the place that they intersect is a node.
We've got a node here and a node here--they're connected.
Node here and node here--they're connected, connected. This is a node and they're connected.
Mark all the intersection points as nodes and put all the pieces of plastic in that connect them as edges.
You can now just focus on that graph. So here's our graph.
It has a total of 26 nodes and 39 edges and what we're looking for in this graph--
we're going cut edges, we're going to remove edges to make a tree.
Right--the tree is going to be connected and have no turtle catchers
which we in graph theory call cycles.
How many edges are in a tree where 26 nodes, 25. How many do we have--39.
Well, we're going to have to kill 14 edges to turn this into a tree.
I first discovered this trick quite by accident that I actually was cutting up the little ring things
that saved the turtles and a surprise, that no matter how I did, I always seem to
to come out with the same number and then I realize it was just a graph theory problem.